[Music]
the greatest lecture or sermon you will
give is your example what you do will
matter far more than what you say as my
grandfather often said we were
duty-bound to do the right thing
to do unto others as we would have them
do unto us in a sense they were teaching
us that what we wanted to do did not
define what was right
rather what was right defined what we
were required to do and what we were
permitted to do at the risk of
understating what it is necessary to
preserve liberty and our form of
government I think more and more that it
depends on good citizens discharging
their daily duties and their daily
obligations some of you will most
assuredly be called upon to do the very
hard things to preserve Liberty perhaps
even give the last full measure but all
of you will be called upon to provide
that firm foundation of citizenship by
carrying out your obligations and much
the way that those around you did and so
many did during my youth you are to be
the example to others that they were to
you the very existence of Hillsdale
connotes independence it understands
that Liberty is an antecedent of
government not a benefit from government
do not hide your faith and your beliefs
under a bushel basket especially in this
world that seems to have gone mad with
political correctness I admit to being
unapologetically Catholic
unapologetically patriotic and
unapologetically a constitutionalists
after the Constitutional Convention in
Philadelphia Benjamin Franklin remarked
when asked what they had done that they
had be given us a republic if we can
keep it are we content to let others do
the work to let a few give the last full
measure for liberty while we consume the
benefits if so perhaps one day we will
run out of other people's sacrifice and
courage and perhaps we will run out of
courageous people willing to make the
sacrifice
but this is Hillsdale College and you're
special that shining city on a hill
Hillsdale is a trustee of the Heritage
that finds as fierce expression in the
American experiment of self government
under law you are men and women of
Hillsdale College a school that has
stood fast on its principles and its
traditions at great sacrifice and great
costs you are men and women of Hillsdale
steeped in the best traditions and
principles of our great nation
if you don't lead by example
who will I have every faith that you
will be the beacon of light for others
to follow that city on a hill that
cannot be hidden may God bless each of
you now and throughout your lives and
may God bless america
[Applause]